he's done
I just have to say you are both so
incredible and honey you inspire me
every time I watch you dancing what kind
of pressures are you feeling and how do
you deal with that
honestly it's this guy on top of me just
staying present I think because a lot of
the time I can get ahead of myself I
would say this week was one of those
weeks super challenging you know I had a
back injury and a hip injury so it was
just a ton and I got kind of caught in
the whirlwind but I just have to remind
myself this is fun and this is something
that I've always wanted to do and I only
have one shot to do it helps you get
through the pain a little bit
how is the pain hours like I mean where
are you now with that cuz you certainly
didn't show like you were hurt very much
outfit thank you know it's been a
struggle like I'm a lot better than
yesterday even I had some therapy
earlier I've been icing it and taking a
bunch of medicine so I'm in the frosted
field boat oh yeah no not 100% but I'm
getting
landy more
[Applause]
[Music]
I also got a comment your score this
week a perfect score I've been waiting
on it right yeah come on Thank You Lin
well I was gonna say thank you Lin from
you but I'll see you bad you know you've
had a few words would lend very kind
words but still so I mean how does it
feel for you sir and feels awesome it's
nice to to finally build a relationship
with someone I've listened to for the
last seven years and it's nice for him
to validate my work as a teacher and her
work as a performer especially
considering the fact you had to make
adjustments I mean obviously had the
physical limitations you had to make
adjustments in the dance last minute and
then I mean you just nailed it thank you
it all fell into place happened the way
it was supposed to so I'm grateful
[Music]
you
[Music]